der marley einsatz ist der größte
einsatz der bundeswehr wir haben dort
4400 soldaten vor ort wir sind über zehn
jahre dort ich bin selber dreimal im
einsatz dort gewesen und ich bin der
meinung wir sollten jetzt ganz geplant
und langsam abziehen werden bei der
mandatsvergabe gesagt wir überprüfen das
quasi wir geben noch mal ein jahr zeit
und es gibt gewisse bedingungen wo wir
uns dann überlegen den einsatz zu
beenden und meine argumente sind wie
folgt ich finde wir können den auftrag
dort nicht wahrnehmen ja wir haben also
die möglichkeit müssen auf tagesbasis
beurteilen ob wir unseren auftrag
erfüllen können für diese un mission die
un mission kann unter den derzeitigen
bedingungen mit der putschregierung
keine stabilität und keine stabile
arbeit umsetzen den friedensprozess
nicht vorantreiben und außerdem ist die
sicherheit der soldaten natürlich auch
mittelbar gefährdet dadurch dass wir
quasi immer wieder überfluggenehmigungen
nicht erhalten die golden hour nicht
einhalten können und damit eben die
operationelle beim range sehr limitiert
ist vom lager hat ich bin der meinung
wir sollten dort geplant abziehen aber
im rahmen der zeit wir müssen wir unsere
verantwortung auch wahrnehmen das heißt
wir müssen gleichzeitig überlegen gehen
wir vielleicht auch wieder rein mit
einem neuen mandat mit einer ganz
zugeschnittene aufgabe mit zielen die
wir haben und einem klaren zeitablauf
was passiert denn wenn die bundeswehr
abzieht was passiert dann da das ist
natürlich wir sind im rahmen der
un-mission minustah eingebettet das sind
ungefähr 15.000 soldaten
wir sind eine der nationen die die
hochwertigsten fähigkeiten dort stellt
das natürlich ein schwerer schlag und
darum sind wir auch noch da aber das
außen- und sicherheitspolitische wichtig
ist dass wir da sind aber wir müssen
natürlich auch überlegen was für mandat
haben wir vom un-sicherheitsrat also was
sollen wir dort lösen und ich sehe im
moment nicht dass wir das dass wir eben
stabilität den friedensprozess von
algier dort weiter bringen in der
jetzigen lage und ich sehe auch nicht
dass sich das absehbar verändern wird
nichtsdestotrotz müssen wir stabilität
in die region bringe das machen wir zum
beispiel im niger mit der operation
taguba wo wir eben niedrig das militär
ausbilden aber mit klaren
qualitätsstufen um essen wo wir sagen in
einem jahr ist es vorbei dass wir uns
auch ganz klar wirklich evaluieren was
wir dort wirklich tun china kauft sie
sind ja experte auch für die thematik
und wie eigentlich für auslandseinsätze
aber wie sehen sie das hier in dem
zusammenhang also was heißt erklärte gut
ich war vor langer zeit waren die beiden
herren noch gar nicht auf der welt war
ich heute bei der luftwaffe war im
schlaf weiter gespart und dann war ich
22 jahre lang mitglied im beirat für
innere führung des verteidigungsminister
kann man sie als experten bezeichnen
zwar haben die gäste erlebt da habe ich
auch truppen im ausland besucht im
kosovo und so weiter und so weiter mehr
ich war ab 92 in diesem beirat und ich
war von den auslandseinsätzen bis
einschließlich zuletzt afghanistan und
morde überzeugt aber ich teile jetzt
ihre auffassung der major wenn ich sie
so ansprechen darf nachdem die franzosen
als die führende und stärkste kraft dort
mit 4000 soldaten abgezogen sind und
nach dem tod hin
personalisierte das mal so mit seiner
gruppe wagner dort einmarschiert muss es
uns der verteidigungsministerin und dem
bundeskanzler und der generalität um die
fürsorgepflicht für unsere soldaten
gehen und dann muss es heißen raus damit
welche bäder erwarten uns denn johannes
wenn ich daran denke was uns nach
afghanistan erwartet hat das war ja
schon auch als bürgerin entsetzlich zu
sehen wenn wir aus mali rausgehen was
erwartet uns dann und nicht dass wir die
bilder schlümpfen zu ertragen sein was
erwartet natürlich die menschen vor ort
es gibt eine studie von april die sagt
dass wir vor allen dingen im nahbereich
der bases quasi wirklich sicherheit
erzeugen und für die menschen sicherheit
verbessern aber nur in diesem bereich
der base empfinden wir eine verbesserte
sicherheit ich glaube wenn wir dort
abziehen müssen wir das wirklich geplant
tun also nicht in wenigen wochen sondern
sagen wir machen das auch über ein
prozess mehrere monate bis ich zum
beispiel in afghanistan material schützt
unser personal wir nehmen unsere
sprachmittler unsere lokalen
angestellten mit und deren familien um
die müssen wir uns kümmern das ist ein
ganz ganz wichtiges thema
bleiben wie soll man das lösen wie ich
habe das ja gesagt ich möchte mich der
verantwortung nicht entziehen wolle das
heißt zeiten wenn da auch wir müssen
endlich sicherheitspolitisch
erwachsenwerden und das habe ich das
gefühl da sind wir mal nicht wir müssen
also darüber nachdenken wie können wir
diese region weiterhelfen aber mit einem
begrenzten mandat mit klaren aufgaben
und auch ganz ganz klar ein qualitäts
messpunkten das wäre mir sehr wichtig
dass wir also über beides nachdenken
abzug jetzt weil so bringt es nichts
aber überlegen wie wir vielleicht das
problem weiterhin wir brauchen wir noch
einen weiteren perspektiven wechseln ja
die bundeswehr war ab 1990 91 92 sehr
stark fokussiert auf auslandseinsätze
und hat die landesverteidigung
vernachlässigt ja personal abgebaut
friedensdividende zugunsten von
sozialpolitischen wohltaten und wir
wissen ja manche waffensysteme haben nur
noch eine einsatzfähigkeit von 40 45
prozent bestimmt der hubschrauber und so
weiter wer nachwuchsproblem 20 tausend
dienstposten sind nicht besetzt
gleichzeitig wollen wir von 183.000 auf
203.000 kommen weiß gar nicht wo die
alle herkommen sollen wer soll da macht
das 40.000 ja da muss man diese
perspektivischen perspektive wechseln
mit machen ja auch wieder nicht zuletzt
wegen hoher preise und gerade das ist
zwar da bin ich bin ich bin der meinung
wir sollten diesen fehler von anfang
90er jahre nicht wiederholen als wir
jetzt sagen wir vergessen jetzt auf
einmal auslandseinsätze und machen nur
noch landes und bündnisverteidigung ist
jetzt weniger er muss der schwerpunkt
liegen aber wir müssen weiter noch die
kleine insel
ich glaube beides gleichberechtigt wird
wahrscheinlich schwer werden mit den
kräften und nichts über den aber müssen
die fähigkeiten in beiden bereichen
behalten und bei bedarf eben auch in das
ausland ausgerichtet worte reichen die
100 milliarden nicht die 100 milliarden
reichen vielleicht jetzt die nächsten
vier jahre um das 2 prozent nahezu zu
100 milliarden ja dazu quasi dass wir
wieder das auffüllen was wir jetzt viele
jahre aus den regalen
die herren schon wieder unterbrechen
aber unsere sendezeit ist zu ende